the Joe Rogan experience did you know
that horses originally evolved here in
North America no and then they went
exactly what and then they reintroduced
them really the Europeans did yeah
there's a guy named Dan Flores he's got
a bunch of great books and one of them
is called coyote America he's got
another one what is this other book
about the the various large land animals
that went extinct here in North America
but that the wolf and a lot of the other
ones wasn't concern getti that's it
natural wealth oh yeah yeah he's
fantastic and essentially they all went
extinct all the horses went extinct here
and then they were reintroduced by
Europeans but they had originally
evolved here and flirting America I
didn't know so there's no but there's no
evidence that any of the Native people
here really used them until Europeans
came whether it was Cortes or whoever
you know what Cortes with the Aztecs or
whoever else came across horses a horse
is so much a part of this story the you
know but so they come up with the
Spanish the Spanish are acutely aware of
what is going to happen if the horse
technology gets out and they take great
pains to not let it get out they don't
want to teach the Indians in Mexico or
the Indians in North America how to use
them but inevitably the technology does
get out and then there's a few moments
there's a great moment in time in 1680
in Santa Fe when there's a great Pueblo
Revolt and they kick the Spanish out in
like tens of thousands of horses get out
it's the great horse dispersal and and
and these are the horses that come into
the hands of the police Plains tribes so
it was in the 1600s that their power and
their dominance started to assert itself
begins the Comanches figure out how to
have all these horses and how valuable
that was or some of the other tribes
just hadn't kind of caught on
no one knows and and it's interesting no
one knows that because you it was only
seen in flashes by the Spanish through
their kind of northern outpost no one
exactly knows what it was you know in
the heart and soul of a Comanche that
could do that better than anybody else
but in
fact comanches but by all descriptions
of the time were not pre horse and they
wait graceful people they were kind of
short and kind of you know bowlegged and
they they weren't especially graceful
and and they didn't they didn't look
like perhaps you would have think of the
the northern Sioux Indians of the neck
on the nickel I mean that kind of tall
and you know with the bone structure
that wasn't the Comanches and then they
got on a horse and then everything
changed and and and even though the
Apaches were the first ones to actually
get that technology from the Spanish and
they crazed they raised havoc with it
but the tribe that got it the best and
the most were the Comanches they were
the tribe that actually ended up
supplying horses to a lot of the
Northern Plains tribes that we just
talked about and what they did with once
they had this incredible mastery of the
horse and this ability to hunt like they
never had and fight like they never had
they did what you would I guess expect
the great new power and the planes and
the planes are a big place by though I
mean the great new power of the place
it's got a challenge for the greatest
food source out in mid-america and that
was the buffalo herds and they were in
the southern plains so the Comanches
over a period of 150 years of sustained
combat moved south from the Wind River
mountains of Wyoming essentially into
this 250,000 square mile empire think of
kind of headquartered in the pick Texas
Panhandle which is where the buffalo
were and this tribe they were known for
being buffalo hunters and they were also
known that they weren't really like
making art work or doing a lot of the
things that we sort of associate with
other Native American tribes or mostly
just hunting they were writing and
things that we all would associate with
Native Americans you know this wonderful
abilities and dance and music complex
religion and complex religious social
structures to go along with it and all
these different things music and dance
and all these things the Comanches by
the time that the kind of Anglo
Europeans run into them they are a
stripped down culture that looks more
like Sparta and one of the reasons they
are is because they
fighting this long war primarily against
the Apaches but against other tribes
over decades and during that time as
they became ascendant militarily they
became less interested in those things
they became interested in war conveyed
status right war conveyed numbers of
ponies and Status and the thing and so
yes they were they were a stripped-down
war culture I guess to whatever extent
we we know or something about sparred I
would remind you of Sparta that's what's
so interesting about it is is such a
unique tribe just a very unique branch
of Native Americans that was
specifically like this they made war and
they and they conquered and when you
know when you think about what they got
themselves finally it's about I said
250,000 square miles this probably
doesn't mean anything but think of West
Texas western Oklahoma western Kansas
eastern Colorado and eastern New Mexico
gigantic chunks of that that was theirs
and and when you think of the numbers of
them that were there when when say the
Anglo Europeans and the Americans came
through in the 1830s there was probably
25 or 30,000 of them out there of which
five or six thousand warriors now I
don't know what five or six thousand
suggests you but it suggests to me like
the third base line at Yankee Stadium or
something it's not very many people
mm-hmm you know occupying this gigantic
area that that became as we were saying
earlier determinants of everything that
happened around it
[Applause]